after the second day of Kampala scape
the violence are starting to return to
their battered neighborhoods in
Northeast Delhi in Schenck bag they've
come back to widespread destruction and
loss it was very stressful living here
during the last few days we were all
extremely scared so scared that we moved
all our woman to a safer place only the
men stayed people were killed and
injured here homes and businesses were
burned Mohammed's fruit and vegetable
shop provided a livelihood for his
family for 30 years he was burned during
the riots and he's not insured he is
part of the Muslim community that
suffered the worst of the violence but
he's not vengeful we have to live
peacefully together whatever has
happened we have to treat it as a
one-off we have to forget we can't just
blame the Hindus or Muslims both groups
were there three shops down is his
neighbor Ganesh it was a Hindu his fruit
and veg shop was also burnt but even
after losing his livelihood he still
believes in coexistence when there is
peace we can once again start our
business we have to do it to survive to
earn our living there is no other way to
earn a living it's a seed of hope that
Hindus and Muslims can return to the
peaceful coexistence they enjoyed for
years a senior police commissioner
visited Chang bag Thursday to reassure
locals that peace has been restored but
it's the presence of large numbers of
security forces that people find more
reassuring not words are known this is a
very public confidence-building measure
designed to show people that the
security forces have control of the
streets and it's now safe but many
people are asking the question where
were they when they needed them most
Delhi Police have been heavily
criticised over its handling of the
violence which has been described as a
best negligent and worse complicit
families are slowly returning to this
battleground feeling more apprehensive
than safe it seems to be peace and calm
but we lost everything after our home
was set on fire we only managed to
salvage this cooking gas
but others like this Hindu family have
decided to leave the district altogether
the riot situation has scared us a lot
that's why we're going back to our
village where it's safer the streets
will be cleared the debris removed and
homes rebuilt but these communities
cannot fully heal until those
responsible face justice
Tony Berkeley al Jazeera Shan bag
northeast Delhi